welcome to the latest dining street
press conference we first
run you through the latest data on
our coronavirus response
four million seven hundred and eighty
six thousand
two hundred and nineteen tests for
coronavirus have now been carried out
or posted out in the uk including 171
829 tests yesterday
279 856 people
have tested positive and that's an
increase of 1871 cases
since yesterday 7485 people are in
hospital
with kovid 19 in the uk down
16 from 8921
this time last week and sadly of those
who tested positive for coronavirus
across all settings
39 700
have now died that's an increase of 359
fatalities since yesterday and once
again we're with their families
in mourning now that the rate of
transmission in the uk has
fallen significantly from its peak we
need to take
steps to manage the flare-ups and stop
the virus from
re-emerging i want to update you on the
progress we're making on three fronts
to prevent a second wave of infections
that could
overwhelm the nhs
first we've set up nhs test and trace
in order to identify contain and control
the virus
in the uk thereby reducing its spread
as we move to the next stage of our
fight against coronavirus
we'll be able to replace national
lockdowns
with individual isolation and if
necessary
local action where there are outbreaks
nhs test and trace will be vital to
controlling the spread
of the virus it's how we will be able to
protect our friends and family
from infection and protect our nhs and
it does this
by identifying anyone who's been in
close contact
with someone who's tested positive
asking them
to isolate for 14 days in order to avoid
unknowingly
infecting others and the system clearly
relies
on everyone playing their part
so i want to stress again today
we need you to get a test
if you have coronavirus symptoms a high
temperature
a new continuous cough or a loss of
taste
or smell there is plenty of capacity
and everyone with symptoms is eligible
every everyone with symptoms so please
order a test from
nhs dot uk forward slash
coronavirus as soon as you develop
symptoms
and we need you to isolate
yourself if a contact tracer tells you
that you have been in contact with
someone who's tested positive
nhs test and trade started operating a
week ago and already thousands of people
are isolating who wouldn't have been
doing so before this service was
introduced and
they are thereby protecting others and
reducing the spread
of the virus so while we're going to
all these efforts here in the uk to
control the virus
we must also ensure we don't reimport
the virus from abroad so
the second action i want to update you
on is the introduction of public health
measures
at the border today the home secretary
has brought forward
the legislation needed to establish the
new regime
from monday and i want to explain the
reasons for introducing
these measures now when coronavirus
started to spread around the world
first from wuhan and then from northern
italy and other areas
we introduced enhanced monitoring at the
border
in an attempt to stop the virus from
getting a foothold in the uk
these measures applied at various
different times to arrivals from
china japan iran and italy
and required people with symptoms
traveling from those countries
to self-isolate for 14 days however
once community transmission was
widespread within the uk
cases from abroad made up a tiny
proportion of the total
at the same time you'll remember
international travel
plummeted as countries around the world
went into lockdown
so as a result measures at the border
were halted
because they made little difference at
the time in our fight against
the virus now that we're getting the
virus under control
in the uk there is a risk that cases
from abroad
begin once again to make up a greater
proportion
of overall cases we therefore need to
take steps
now to manage that risk of these
imported cases triggering a second peak
so just as we're asking people already
in the
uk to isolate for 14 days when contacted
by nhs
test and trace we're also asking those
arriving from abroad
to isolate so that they don't
unknowingly
spread the virus there will be some
exemptions
for a limited number of people who need
to cross
the border such as those engaged
directly in the fight against
coronavirus
or who provide essential services and we
will review
how the policy is working after three
weeks and of course
we will explore the possibility of
international travel corridors
with countries that have low risks of
low rates
of infection but only when the
evidence shows that it is safe to do so
the third point i want to make today is
we need effective
international action to reduce the
impact of the virus
across the globe and this is the the
moment really for humanity to unite
in the fight against the disease
health experts have warned that if
coronavirus
is left to spread in developing
countries that could lead
to future ways of infection coming back
and reaching the uk
while our amazing nhs has been there for
everyone in this country who
needs it many developing countries have
health care systems
which are ill-prepared to manage this
pandemic so to ensure
that the world's poorest countries have
the support they need to slow the spread
of the virus
tomorrow i will open the global vaccine
summit
hosted by the uk and will bring together
more than 50 countries and
leading figures like bill gates to raise
at least at least
7.4 billion dollars for gaddy the
vaccine alliance
over the next five years with the uk's
support as gabby's biggest
donor this vaccine alliance aims to
immunize
a further 300 million children in the
poorest countries
against deadly diseases like polio
typhoid and measles
again saving millions of lives
this support for routine immunizations
will shore up
poorer countries healthcare systems to
deal with coronavirus
and so help to stop the global spread
and as i say
prevent a second wave of the virus
reaching the uk
this virus has shown how connected we
are we're fighting
an invisible enemy and no one is safe
frankly until
we're all safe and again of course this
is
all contingent upon each of us
continuing
to do our bit and and as i never tire of
telling you let us not
forget the basics wash your hands
regularly and for 20 seconds wash your
hands
do not gather in groups of more than six
outside
always observe social distancing keeping
two meters apart from anyone
outside your household and
i want to stress one final point which
may be relevant
uh today is that as the weather
threatens i think to take a turn
for the worse some of you may be tempted
to move the gatherings you've been
enjoying outdoors
indoors out of the rain
i really urge you don't do that
we relax the rules on meeting outside
for a very specific reason
because the evidence shows that the
risks of transmission are much lower
outdoors much lower outdoors and
the risks of passing on the virus is
significantly higher indoors which is
why
gatherings inside other people's homes
are still
prohibited breaking these rules
now could undermine and reverse all the
progress that we've made
together i've no doubt that that won't
happen
i've no doubt that won't happen i think
the british public will continue
to show the same resolve in fighting the
virus as they have throughout
this outbreak we will get through this
if we stay alert
control the virus and in doing so save
lives